je m'aperçois que les filles de la
campagne ne tiennent pas tellement à se
marier avec un gars de campagne parce
qu'elles veulent aller plutôt vers la
ville une femme aime bien son dimanche
son samedi alors que dans l'agriculture
on n'est pas libre je me trouve assez
bien comme ça vous savez j'ai 22 ans et
demi je me trouve très bien comme ça et
vous pensez trouver l'âme sœur à la fois
au célibataire bah peut-être vous
n'auriez pas souhaité vous marier il y a
4 ça ne va pas comment on veut on ne
prend pas n'importe qui vaut mieux
cocher tout seul qui touche à une femme
qu'on n'aime pas j'étais pour me marier
et puis j'étais trompée avant le mariage
alors je vais abandonné celui qui s'est
passé il est souvent mieux seul qui
était avec une femme qui n'y connaît
rien tu en as pas mal qui ne connais pas
grand chose
avec l'espoir de trouver quelqu'un ah
oui mais pas pour peut-être pas pour le
mariage sûrement pas ça vous a pas
manqué quand même un homme tout au long
de votre vie
un ou deux
oh j'ai dit un péché